it Bart's like Devil's Advocate maybe
there's a new cell mate who wants to get
his butt cheese I'll be Devil's Advocate
maybe he doesn't know what time
I'm on his side I'm on the side that's
why the show has lasted so long we don't
know time incredible analysis
[Music]
I got admit I kind of laughed when I
read this one
there's this dude who's going let me
just show you this photo because we need
some visual context every now and then
we want visual contact thank you dude
you're welcome my favorite here saving a
whole Nick question
I don't ask him anymore that's the same
guy yeah same guy he's here to make any
judgments why'd you turn up the
brightness
yeah dude I didn't need it to be
brighter I knew I saw it yeah I sound
perfectly fine totally fine dude am I
crazy yeah it's just me you know what
it's kind of [__] up you did that
actually yeah
I don't know what you're trying to buy
um I need to write an editor why did you
spam the why did you spam the brightness
you turn it up way too high yeah yeah
it's a little too bright
sweating
Anthony broke his [__] brightness
button it keeps going up dude it's
pressing by itself
all right this guy I don't know how to
[__] pronounce his name I think it's
Shina Kendrick
where's he from Huffman uh he actually
fled a central Mississippi Correctional
Facility last year in August right oh
[__] got a seven year sentence and he
was months away from completing any
escaped all right he escaped we got a
few months left he's 20 21 years old he
broke into a Local's home and held
people at gunpoint before he stole one
of the hostages cars that's like another
20 30
you should have just
done what was his original charge seven
uh I don't know what the original
charger but he he has seven years on but
he was a couple months left
done [__] oh [__] where to god dude
one day the host is gonna take you
outside and kick it till you're dead
bite the curb dude just beat the [__]
out of me I'm gonna jump you guys hey
guys see you later great day today
what are you doing by my car hey what's
up Steve we should just add him to the
spreadsheet so he can read it the day
before
[Laughter]
I'll do my own research yeah so this guy
this guy holds a local you know people
at gunpoint he takes their car and he
crashes Ford Taurus yeah dude that's
totally Capricorn energy dude are you
sure this guy's a Capricorn you know he
is exactly he crashes the car and he
tries to flee on foot he's like well
what shoes does he wearing Air Max 95
start making [__] up
telling you you think he's like a size
34 waist what do you think he doesn't
get too far if they would build blast
pants yeah and then the police find him
hiding in a bin at a Mississippi State
Hospital in Whitfield two miles away
from the prison so he's locked up again
a couple hours later after his breakup
breakout right and then he gets
sentenced to another 40 years see I had
his back yeah bro just finish the time
you can't do that bro you got a couple
months dude it was aggravated assault
was the first charge expected to be
released this December that's insane
that's so funny to go to jail for seven
years and you go I have a plan to get
out
six and a half years
ah if I have to play Devil's Advocate
every night he was like I got time and I
have to try to like empathize with him
why he broke out with only a few months
left
it could be
they got a new
cell mate that's trying to be his
[__] man daddy that's what I was
thinking too and he's like oh tonight
I'm gonna go bust up those chops and
he's like I gotta get the [__] out of
here
it's probably getting bullied yeah you
might have a new inmate but do you think
he had like a little bit of you know
that space awareness be like all right I
might only be this dude's [__] for a
couple months it's not that bad I mean
dude for six years he went unscathed he
was nobody's [__] for six years yeah
but they might they might transfer in
the new guy all of a sudden we're like
we'll do some damage that's what they do
to you dude every single time right at
the end of your sentence they that's the
hardest part of their test they're like
all right we're gonna put in a new cell
mate who wants your [__] cheeks we
need to make sure you never come back
maybe he didn't know that he had a
couple months left yeah maybe I feel
like everyone's counting their days
maybe he doesn't know time like months
is like he doesn't remember being like a
kid and be like 30 minutes and you're
like oh no I don't even know like how
long 30 minutes is but it felt a long
time
way I was like that's forever he's smart
enough to escape prison but he doesn't
know time yeah Bart's like Devil's
Advocate maybe there's a new cell mate
who wants to [__] get his butt cheese
I'll be Devil's Advocate maybe he
doesn't know what time
I'm on his side I'm on the side it is in
no time that's why the show has lasted
so long we don't know time incredible
analysis there's definitely something
that's happening in prison though that
like makes a dude get out and just
repeat a fan first thing he's out yep
there's definitely some part of logic
that isn't there well there's guys that
find more Comfort there than on in the
real world yeah or there's just like a
there's definitely something that where
they're not giving the sense of hope
that you can be anything else other than
what you are like I think I think real
real life is made into real right I know
sorry hanging into real I also think
it's probably the entrepreneurial
seminars they have in there yeah so if
you're in there right and then you got
another guy coming what you're coming
for oh dude I gotta [__] I'm making
million dollars a month while I'm here
when you're making million dollars a
month while you're in here how do I get
involved yeah so I feel like you're
having like all these other
entrepreneurs but like on the other side
of the fence and they're all pitching
each other's sick ass [__] ideas they
probably can't wait to go do when they
get out right you know exactly
documentaries are you watching planet
Earth no I had a co-worker that was like
dude like when you when you have a you
know sheet like when you have a record
he goes you don't have many options for
jobs like you get out and he's like
you're like working in a meat factory
whatever and then he was um
what do you call it those job agencies
where you just kind of sign up and then
you're working along like doing random
jobs like construction whatever right
like a temp temp agency so we would get
guys from temp agencies to work in our
warehouse and then he was telling me
like yeah like when I was broke he goes
I would just I would just go to jail I'm
like what do you mean he goes I make way
more money in jail than I do out here
and then I was like so how do you make
money he goes oh I just bring in drugs
and sell drugs and then they take care
of you so like I don't have bills so
he's like if I can't pay my bills I
can't do whatever I just need to reset
he goes I just I just go in he goes I
just you know maybe shoot some rounds in
the air call the cops on myself and then
like you know I'd be caught with a gun
or whatever and he goes I know how much
time I'm gonna do so I'll be like okay
I'll be in there for maybe like a six
months a year and then so during that
time he goes like they feed you you
don't have any bills to pay you're just
selling drugs and then he's like you
fill up your account and then you're out
how does he get the drugs in yeah and
how does he feel up his account how
about how does he his it's called a
prison pie so one time yeah but also too
it's like how how far does it have to go
up where they check you and they don't
see it
I don't know man we have a buddy who's
of all these questions that need to be
answered obviously what size waist is
this pants my my buddy who's a deputy
sheriff said that one guy one time they
were at the courts and then this guy was
having his hearing and he kept like
moving around and he goes man there's
something in there and then and then
they they booty searched them and a gun
popped out like a revolver like he had a
[__] gun in his butthole 38 huh yeah
yeah
beat the gun he's just really happy I'm
surprised that thing didn't go off well
the bullets were separate they put them
up first like I hope so when I download
the clip but I never heard of something
you know when guys talk so badass about
these things but the whole time I just
can't stop thinking about it's all in
your butthole yeah but you had to
prepare your butt and get your butt red
nice and ready you know it's a very
Macho discussion like I'm they're going
to jail they're doing this but everyone
avoids the whole process of it's going
right up the ass yeah yeah they don't
want to mention that it's not the
Glamorous part it's not it's not you
don't see that in the movies very much
the butthole Parts the butthole part
that's the true entrepreneurs the
butthole smuggling there should be a
documentary though made about a [__]
revolver coming out of the guy's ass in
court yeah I think that's pretty it's
not bad they did it the cool way with
Snoop Dogg and Training Day you know
what Denzel makes him throw up and he
throws up all those like balloons of
cocaine or whatever but that's another
way that people hide it too oh they just
swallow it when the cops come it's like
when they mule it across the border too
yeah it seems like a big it's better
than having uh Snoop Dogg [__] take a
diarrhea on the side of the sidewalk and
seeing all kinds of cocaine come out
remember the dude in Con Air
the dude in Cony are on there on the
thing where he like pulls out the
[__] oil and [__] like that yeah
it's better than coming out the other
way no that would have been an epic
version of the movie
another way that they do it is through
the guards and through the cops
that seems like the most reliable yeah
that way you can actually replenish your
supply otherwise you just got it's a
you're one and done I mean it seems like
most [__] is through the actual
establishment because everybody's
[__] recording and streaming from
jail I saw it that's pretty I saw a sad
ass one I don't know what page I
followed but they show some crazy [__] I
don't know what picture was like a lady
with uh her her baby maybe like four
four years old as her son and they're
visiting like Dad in jail and then so
they get to have one of those rooms you
know and then so the this the dad was
the inmate
um is holding his son like this and he's
just rocking and he's like talking to
his wife and then you see it hit the dad
like caress uh the son's face and then
on like the third caress you pull
something out of the sun's mouth and he
puts in his pocket like the kid is the
one that yeah I saw that one and I was
like what the [__] you just never know
did you guys follow the same pages
and they and the prison got they found
out immediately they saw it they were
watching the whole thing it's [__]
great I wouldn't have if I was like a
prince I'm eating [__] Krispy Kremes
and [__] like I would have missed it
those guys got laser eyes there was
there's another video of a prisoner
riding out the guard and he's recording
the guard uh accepting stuff from like a
visitor to give to the people whoa just
like ratting out the actual guard rival
drug dealer right mind mind your
business dude
yeah it's crazy it really is like it's a
crazy operation dude yeah you know like
the meth not even once campaign it is
kind of like jail it's like if you
[__] go the first time that's way
[__] bad like yeah you're probably
gonna now you're gonna pick up some bad
habits you're gonna be in that culture
and you might be worse off like
statistically like because you're just
entering a different world now yeah
that's why when you see people that get
out and they're better people it's like
how the [__] did you do that yeah
because there's so many challenges that
you usually read a bunch yeah that mean
that's what herc did yeah they just read
a ton and they're like I just stayed by
myself and I just did that well also
Hurricane's a [__] Hulk so you're not
gonna [__] with him anyway so it's like
yeah and he was in Federal which is a
different caliber of criminal
which is um they're more sophisticated
and and intelligent in the way that they
do things or they're just hardcore
versus like County jail and all that
they're they're they're more like yeah
can you turn the brightness on your
screen
[Music]
foreign